do have a very special guest right now
with us in the studio a man that played
a tremendous game today that is
leveronian lev welcome to the studio
welcome to st louis welcome back to
saint louis tell us a little bit about
the format of the event how do you
approach it and how do you feel about
the format of this event
um
i think
when you play chess for uh 30 years you
don't care about the format
you're just happy to be in front of the
board
and to have a chance to compete with
some of the best players in the world so
it's uh
i mean i'm happy with every format but
of course the format is very exciting
because
normally uh one mistake and you're gone
in a
knockout tournament here you have a
chance to you know
be kind of a zombie and come back
come back to life
tell us a little bit about this
particular matchup against ray robson i
was doing some research and i couldn't
find any games between youtube
is this a completely new opponent for
you
yes we have never played which is quite
surprising because
ray is an established player
you know i have
high regard for him as one of the most
talented players
from america
but surprisingly yeah we've never played
and yet today was our first game and it
worked well for me quite an intense game
let's uh go through that one take us
through the opening phase
uh actually we got to this point uh
lavon a very interesting but only we
won't ask you about your preparation but
after the move a2 a3
take it from here how did you like your
position and
what was your feeling
i can't really say i like my position
but
this is
not the type of position that ray has
played before i he he kind of surprised
me with first movie six and that he went
for this line
and i was thinking okay position is
quite balanced and uh yeah at this
moment this was definitely a critical
moment in the game after knight b3
uh because so far i think all rays move
make perfect sense sure and here i think
he went for this inaccurate b6 i thought
that after 95
knight edgar five yeah yep
the the problem was that i was kind of
hoping that knight d4 would work but it
doesn't at all because bishop takes a4
queen a4 knight d3
rookie three and knight f2
is crashing
nice because king of two queen f6 knight
f3 queen b2 and
yeah this is some yum yum time
very nice variations for sure and so i
thought what am i going to do because
from distance i thought maybe i have
this knight c5 after knight e5 uh yeah
knight
95 knight bc5
bishop c6 uh knight b7 i thought maybe
this will work but it also doesn't work
because bishop takes g2 king g2
and queen d7 is extremely powerful here
because
after knight
bc5 queen c6 f3
knight g4
is very painful
otherwise white is doing fine but this
knight g4 is extremely painful
wow
so i probably had to opt for something
like f4 here after knight bc5 bishop c6
and
f4
and hope for
equality like something like f4 here
yeah i see yeah i really need to push
this knight away because he's
feeling
too good this night there exactly so you
were very happy about this opportunity
with the move b6 to play the move bishop
take c6 yeah because after this at least
i'm never worse i just want to point out
the fact that actually this game has
been seen before in five games and
knight to e5 does give black the
advantage
with the variation that you showed
wow
were you aware of that even no no
you study you prepare but not to that
depth that you could guess yeah yeah
really
i was surprised guys yeah give me a
break
hey look i'm completely with you
uh and quickly after d4 f3
everything went very smoothly it felt uh
lavon after yeah well i was thinking
that the position should be slightly
better for me but uh it's nothing really
special and here of course it looks very
good you know he had this funny option
i'll just quickly show you with the
bishop on c7
he has this rook fd8
uh
right now yeah yeah i have to play rook
81 otherwise knight c3 rook before and
he gets tremendous compensation agreed
bishop e5
yeah
but i have to play knight b6 which is
giving me the advantage otherwise
the point is that rook before knight d4
bishop before knight d5 i've got
marvelous that is
yes bishop e5 very very shocking
because of queen f3 yeah yeah this rook
d2 move after these
exactly yeah the funniest part of the
engine wants to play bishop v8 wait for
you to play one of the knights of c3 and
then go bishop e5 ah yeah yeah no i saw
this idea yeah fantastic so essentially
because we've got so much going on lavon
uh we were going to go back
the ending became winning just about
what point in your opinion when did you
say okay this is 90 it's such a
difficult position to play with little
time i thought this is practically
losing for black i see so at this point
it's and then you know this f4 trick is
always working in this position so
this i'm glad i knew yeah that i have
this king d7 f4 and take six f5 okay
exactly yeah exactly so white is winning
because of that f4 f5 f6 thrust exactly
our our resident chess coach coach of
the year
has pointed it out it must be some
classical knowledge lavon
congratulations great start and good
luck in your
game tomorrow
thank you absolutely a pleasure to see
levon playing